on a même une photo de vous avec votre
père avec vous réunis regardez regardez
mais c'est clair qu'il ya un truc hein
valérie benaïm je sais pas si vous le
seriez mais votre sosie travaille dans
une pâtisserie chez bon temps à paris
regardez le solide qu'on nous envoyait
c'est le même phénomène live sauf
qu'elle elle fait des éclairs au café
elle elle fait des makrouts c'est pareil
mais tu es fou bahamas en voilà elles
bronzaient est pas mal non
à ses yeux des yeux j'avais dans les
oreilles les cheveux matthieu delormeau
brad pitt on a déjà fait un nom
ces bundles c'est vrai les gens nous
envoyer ça ouais sauf que lui il a un
petit blond vénitien
ah oui oui il n'ya pas le même bon
effectivement parce qu'il a pas blond
cendré
c'est ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui des
mèches bon vous avez vu la réécouter sur
l' écouteront qu'on n'a pas bossé régine
taussat avait alors au jour
d'aujourd'hui j'ai fait donc j'ai coupé
j'ai fait un colleur five sur les côtés
un colleur five oui absolument pour les
cheveux blancs au dessus j'ai fait une
couleur mais n'est pas musulmane déco
mais j'ai pas mis de patine pour pas que
ça des gorges de soleil et j'ai corrigé
fin fond d'une gorge aux nerfs et vous
verrez des colonnes des gorges le soleil
oui si on fait le coup une patine et
qu'on entretient mal derrière ça des
gorges au soleil savannah cheveux très
jaune
il ne fait pas beau ça dégouline la
couleur vire elle a bien fait pas peur
car que ce soit pas bout qui dirait qu
on ne sent rien deuxième choisi de vous
un peu plus rastkhah c'est helmut couche
commencer un jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
division 2 allemande s'appelle hellmuth
plus chez eux mêmes et dont on ne peut
pas s'appeler né lé contraire c'est un
mélange étrange il perdait ses batteries
de l'embout c'est vrai que ça bouge oui
vous plaît je ne vaux pas dépliants ou
vous fait le ramadan du sexe quoi elle a
une audace à la tête de la berd et quel
point comme c'est sa came ne t'ont pas
ni plaisant et je vais vous faire un
test ophtalmologiques way lui les gosses
vont lui helmut kohl jeu là j'ai pas dit
qu'il était bon moi j'ai dit qu'il
n'était pas déplaisant elle a du charme
mais c'est à dire du charme ou aquila
l'oeil qui pétille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors où nous avons également envoyé un
joli le calibre est nominé à y perdre le
fond hyper bluffant ce sont les malades
c'est pas moi merci me s'échappa
bourreau de maintenant comment s'appelle
votre nom florent laurence m'en excuse
alors en soit c'est plus calme
c'est kelly qu'elle malléable séquelles
il avala bobby hebb 1 il est drôle
celui-ci il est drôle celui-ci il est
très drôle
alors à qui le fait on a un sosie de de
keen'v aussi regarder au nom c'est ce
que nous ont envoyé des tweets au regard
des kings bay mais tant mieux il ya le
nez les oreilles aux régions on est bien
y'a rien il est magnifique c'est un
ancien pompier les gaules et de la mort
à gauche il a fait vieille landes oui
bah je suis désolé lui ancien pont
piéton oui toi t'es grave ma came quoi
c'est vrai alors of gold est ce que
voulait peut-être simule un malaise et
il fait lomu qui l'attend alors alors je
vais vous annoncer une mauvaise nouvelle
oui à l'asie est viré le 20 juin c'est
ma dernière
elle sera pas la peine de revenir
l'année prochaine oh mon dieu je me sens
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le problème avec les pompiers c'est que
quand tu fais pas là quand tu fais pas
la poésie mata couche en fait quand t'as
pas fait la la la la mise à jour tu peux
plus faire ce qu'il faut faire
voilà bah voilà n'est ce pas la même
chose
allez allez vous maintenir en tête à
dégorger c'est bien j'adore il est en
forme
quand ils dorment pas il est au top
alors pas dormi on aa
on a souvent varié le badge tout le
monde dit sur twitter que vous êtes
sosie de quelqu'un ici sérieux ouais ça
rigolait tout le monde l'a comparé bas à
regarder j'arrive et je ne veux pas
critiquer il ya ça pas pour la d2 truc
c'est que quand on sourit lui et moi on
a un point commun le nez descend à venir
je suis comme ça il est normal et si je
fais ça ouais mais ça descend toi si je
me bats aussi oui bonsoir j'ai le sosie
officiel de
du lycée dit me mohamed c'est donc
choisi miss et la production peut
trouver à un personnage qui s'appelle
brique dans la série the middle rica 9
mai son sosie officiel comme à trouver
briques allofs dans la série ça me donne
jean michel maire on s'en souvient il
était venu sur le plateau c'est patrick
oui le mec de dennebroeucq d'ailleurs
selon un tarif là dessus non un coup
devant tant de plus sa jambe et en plus
tu rigoles et qui fait le foot
oui mais non oui oui non non là vous de
la cena pour tous à l'école gynéco on a
reçu un seau lui aussi du dos akouala
ses abonnés
[Applaudissements]
alors les chéris on a également je vous
dis on a reçu une photo du show 10e
une saisie de deux pas de moto c'est pas
nous sur les poteaux ce qui nous envoyer
une photo du sosie de votre papa que
j'adore tellement oui on parle bien de
mon père donc on adore voilà des corps
c'est pas ta alors sur les
téléspectateurs alors mal aux mots je
sais pas s'il est mort de rire
[Applaudissements]
le port non mais sérieux à ces âges
étaient parce que c'était coach olympien
mais c'est vrai que nous des com et le
péru que dans le cas et ça l'est pas
alors on a même une photo de vous avec
avec de votre père avec vous réunis
regardez regardez mais c'est clair qu'il
ya un truc pas les yeux hagards
alors il c'est vrai que les yeux les
yeux sont les mêmes foutez moi quand
même là c'est facile alors il est
certain qu'on le dit elle a les yeux
plus ouvert sur la tête de l'air et et
non à l'extérieur le tout plus ouvert
que oui bah oui madame mieux enfin mais
non mais non mais non benjamin moi je
vois pas comment à castaldi pendant
l'émission parfois s'il vous plaît
direct et on a alors on a reçu s'est
plaint on a aussi quelqu'un qui a vu le
sosie de patrick sébastien gagné 2 se
dit patrick sébastien se dit patrick
sébastien est en train de préférer je
vous le dis mon préféré mais il a deux
d'abord alors il ya aussi eu aussi le
sosie de zinedine zidane
regardez se destine eddine zidane ouais
on peut le respecte et d'ailleurs on
embrasse et l'édition anniversaire non a
enjoint à pipe et bien sûr lembras et je
serai là et il ya le sosie de zlatan
ibrahimovic
regardez c'est mon préféré
[Rires]
avec des joues mais lui est donnée
cézanne ibrahimovic il était prof de
musique c'est pas pour ça mes côtés